[Music]
we saw you on stage looking like a
winter wonderland Queen was it out there
it was amazing you know opening the show
is a little bit nerve-wracking because
you have to get the whole crowd going
but I feel like you're going to save the
year 2019
one of the biggest acts of music to
watch how does that feel and what are
you looking forward to his coming here
excited because like I've been working
really hard for the last 10 years and
just finally have some type of success
it's really cool and it's exciting you
know and just seeing my parents way
proud so I just hope to just keep doing
what I'm doing cuz I really love what I
do like a long did you ever expect this
song with Florida Georgia line to be the
success that it is and did you ever
first see yourself getting into the
country genre oh that was so unexpected
because like I'm a girl I was born in
rate was born in Brooklyn raised in
Staten Island New York and like that I
mean I I respected country music but I
never thought I would have a pop country
song but I guess the best thing things
in life are like unexpected you know
alright is your phone just ringing off
the hook now with people wanting to
collaborate with you um I guess so yeah
like who like who's calling you
oh wow I mean it's a secret here tonight
maybe yes maybe yeah is there a song
with gez coming out you guys are posting
together maybe how do you find time to
balance work and then also your personal
life
I don't flights this year airplanes
every counting those yeah so like it's
hard but like
when I go home for Christmas when my
family is there and my dog is there like
that's like a week is enough for me yeah
that's like every day how are you
spending the holidays do you get a
little bit of a break yeah I get seven
days off that's it just seven days no
that's amazing it's time for you I'm
really happy yeah you mind just pulling
a question out of our what do you
splurge on when it comes to gifts I love
that getting makeup for my friends I
like face masks I'm like I don't know
just something I mean the other day was
it deliver tongs for and my friend
always like told me that she wanted to
leave it on bag that was her goal like
she always want to save up for one so I
got myself one like baking it in the
store and I was actually good for her I
gave it to her and like that was all I
love giving gifts that I love
[Music]